One of the things that's quite
interesting about the gulag camps,
and this is something that's very
relevant to understanding of modern
Russia,
is that so ordinary criminals were put
into the camps and so were political
prisoners,
but the ordinary criminals,
and so those would be rapists and
murderers,
let's say,
as well as thieves who were engaged in
theft as an occupation.
Those were regarded by the Soviets as
socially friendly elements,
and the reason for that was that they
assume that the reason that these people
had turned to crime was because the
approach of the oppressive nature of the
previous czarist slash capitalist system
and that the only reason that these
criminals existed was because they had
been oppressed.
They were oppressed victims of that
system.
And so one of the convenient
consequences of that absolutely insane
doctrine was that the Soviets put the
ordinary criminals in charge of the
camps and these were very,
very seriously bad people.
And so you could imagine the way that
they treated the political prisoners who
were regarded as socially hostile
elements.
Sometimes because of their own
hypothetically traitorous acts,
but more often merely as a consequence
of their racial or ethnic identity or
the fact that they were related by birth
to say people who had been successful
under the previous system,
so who had any,
any association with nobility or any
association with what were known as the
Kulaks who were the only successful
class of former peasants in the Soviet
Union because they were regarded as
privileged.
You may have heard that word more
recently.
They were regarded as privileged and
therefore as enemies of the state,
and it didn't matter if it was your
father or your grandfather or your great
grandfather who happened to be
privileged,
but the mere fact that you were a member
of that group was sufficient reason to
put you into a camp.
And we're talking hundreds of thousands
or perhaps millions of people who
underwent that fate.
And so the idea and the Soviet Union was
just because you were the member of a
class.
Even as a consequence of your familial
association.
You were immediately sufficiently guilty
to be put into a camp and punished.
And the.
And the terms for the camps were often
10 years,
15 years long,
and if you were very fortunate,
you got to have two or three of those.
So the Soviets really instant
implemented and,
and perfected the idea of class and if
this is based guilt and it's a very bad
road to walk down and it's something
that we're very much engaged in at the
moment because there's discussion
everywhere in North America now about
the idea of while race predicated guilt
for example,
and ethnic predicated guilt and some
very bad idea to classify an entire
group of people as guilty of anything
based on their group membership.
So these,
these sorts of things are things we
haven't yet learned and certainly should
have.